Another thing Dr. Bright is not allowed to
do at the Foundation: No unsupervised access
to SCP-387!
SCP-387, or The Living Lego, is a miraculous
find.
It is a tub of seemingly ordinary Lego bricks
that, when built into a shape by human hands,
comes to life and even develops sentience.
Of course, Dr. Bright can never let a cool
thing just exist without wreaking some havoc
with it, and decided to build a tiny lifelike
model of SCP-682.
We have no idea how he built it so fast, or
why it took military-grade explosives to blow
apart a creature made from plastic blocks,
but it was a mess to clean up, and Agent Johnson
will never get his big toe back.
If Dr. Bright is so desperate to play with
Legos, he'll have to stick to the non-magic
kind.